nowadays we spend most of our time at
home
working studying communicating basically
doing everything from home that means
we've also been
stocking up on lots of food
some of you have sent me messages
telling me how much
weight you have gained during the
lockdown
hence up if you have been overeating
just by spending more time at home
let me know in the comments below i mean
what else
do you do 24 7 at home isn't it
plus the food cupboard is literally
right behind you
of course you're going to start reaching
and snacking away
so let's start talking about how you
can't stop
overeating and the cause of it when we
think about
why we eat we often think that it's
because
we're hungry but is that really the case
just take this time to think back when
was the last time
you ate because you were truly hungry
when was the last time you ate
so much you felt absolutely stuffed
how did you feel afterwards did you feel
satisfied
or were you ashamed and felt guilty
the truth is we don't always eat because
we're
hungry did you know that there are eight
different types of hunger
eating too much once in a while is
normal i mean i do that myself
especially if it's a celebration
however if you feel that your eating is
out of control
and you tend to think about food all the
time
then watch this video through it is
important for you to identify your
hunger
if you're constantly binging on foods
and to learn
to recognize why this is happening and
to take the steps to help you to eat
more mindfully
[Music]
this is the real kind of hunger you can
physically
feel the hunger just like when our
bladder stretches
it signals a need to pee when you
physically feel hungry
your stomach starts to grow your blood
sugar level drops your energy is low
and you have a hard time concentrating
on the task
you're doing this is the kind of hunger
where your body truly needs
food and you should be eating listen to
your body's
physical cues and eat when you start to
feel moderately hungry
don't leave it until you feel extremely
hungry because
this can often lead to making really bad
food choices
and eating too much food at one sitting
eating more calories can also lead to
weight gain
does this sound like you i just feel
hungry all the time and i can just
eat and eat and eat and i still don't
feel satisfied
chances are you might be feeding your
body with
crappy meals meals which are high in
calories
but low in nutrients yes you will feel
full but only for a short period of time
after 30 minutes or an hour
you'll start to feel hungry again this
is because our body
naturally craves for nutrients and real
food and because you're not getting
proper nutrients from junk foods
your brain will tell you to eat and eat
but instead of eating a nutrient-dense
meal you end up eating
more crap consume far more calories than
what your body needs
and yet you still don't feel satisfied
it's a vicious
cycle eat crappy food don't get the
nutrients
your body needs don't feel satisfied eat
more crappy food and eventually
whoa where did that extra weight and
tummy
come from if this sounds like you pay
attention to what you feed your body
eat real foods foods that are minimally
processed
and packed with nutrients feeding your
body with nutritious meals
will leave you feeling satisfied for
much longer hence
you won't be in that vicious cycle of
craving for more
if you need help to get started then do
check out my youtube channel for lots of
simple wholesome recipes and also
delicious
meal plans
we live in a culture where we turn to
food to fix
everything we associate food with
happiness
and comfort hence when we feel the
opposite
such as feeling stressed tired bored
lonely sad or angry we turn to food
to try to fix our emotions instead of
dealing with the deeper issue
we want instant gratification because we
want to feel better
it's similar to how some people turn to
alcohol or drugs
it works but for a very short
time when it's over we often end up
feeling
worse and hate ourselves for binge
eating
it's important to recognize that
emotional hunger isn't located in the
stomach
you don't physically feel hungry you
crave
for specific comfort foods for instance
you want to have
ice cream or chocolate to make you feel
better this
often leads to mindless eating instead
of having a few pieces of chocolate or a
few scoops of ice cream
you lose control and end up eating the
entire block of chocolate
or the entire ice cream top and yet
you still don't feel emotionally
satisfied
even when you're extremely stuffed at
the end of
this cycle instead of making you feel
better
you end up feeling shameful regretful
and guilty over the food
you've just eaten if you're an emotional
eater
the next time you're stressed out and
have the urge to reach for a snack
put the food down take three deep
breaths
and ask yourself what am i asking the
food to do for me
if it's linked to an emotional trigger
don't reject the emotion
instead bring awareness to your feelings
and you might be able to find other ways
to satisfy your emotions
if you're feeling down call a friend to
have a chat with or
read a self-development book that might
help you through your issues if you're
stressed out
overworked then just spend five minutes
away from your laptop
or phone just lie down or drink a cup of
tea to calm you down
shift your thinking away from food and
change the action
to feed your emotion not your body
breakfast at 8 00 am lunch at 1 pm
and dinner at 7 pm you eat because you
have trained
your body to eat at a specific time well
there is nothing wrong with this because
in fact
it can be a good eating habit and
prevent overeating
however habit hunger can be an issue
if we subconsciously associate food
to a certain activity for instance do
you snack when you go to the movies
or watch netflix at home let's face it
chances are you're not hungry and you
don't really need to munch
this is a habit which we have developed
over time and now that we're spending
more and more time at home watching tv
that's where
all the extra snacking and calories is
coming from
if this is you start to break the habit
by having a warm cup of tea
or keep your hands busy by doing
something else such as
knitting or arranging a puzzle you
don't have to always keep your mouth
busy
imagine this you already had your lunch
and you're supposed to meet a friend
just over coffee when you're at the cafe
all the cakes and pastries displayed
look so
yummy and you're convinced that they
would taste just as good
suddenly you have more space for food so
instead of just having a cup of coffee
as planned
you end up ordering a piece of cake a
piece of pastry
to go along with your coffee so rather
than listening to what your body needs
you're letting your senses the sight the
smell
and the taste of the food control you if
this sounds like you
before you make an impulsive decision
stop for a moment
look at all the temptations and ask
yourself
am i hungry will eating that piece of
cake
make me feel good afterwards if your
answer is
no i will only feel guilty then
step away you don't need to have it if
however you decided to go ahead and
treat yourself
instead of just scuffing it down enjoy
the cake with
all your senses and share it with your
friend
luke smell take small slow bites to
really
fully appreciate the taste and texture
remember
one slice of cake once in a while won't
make you gain weight
but scuffing them down mindlessly out of
shame on a regular basis
will
[Music]
most of us are probably struggling with
this right now especially if your
country is still in a lockdown i mean
what do you do at home you're probably
spending many hours
watching videos scrolling through social
media while
munching away when you have nothing to
do
it's very tempting to visit the fridge
or grab something from the food cupboard
i mean have you actually counted how
many times you have
opened and closed your fridge and food
cupboard well
start counting and let me know in the
comments below
to fight against this you have to find a
different activity to get outside
the boredom zone immediately if i find
myself
sitting on the couch for more than half
an hour munching away
i will force myself to get up and put on
a workout video from phil
and start working out it's only a 30
minute workout
but it always makes me feel so much
better afterwards
i'm burning and not consuming more
calories
i would also spend time playing with my
dog rusty
and also do some reading to keep myself
and my brain occupied
i think this is in fact the best time
for you to pick up a new hobby of skills
and improve yourself so there's really
no excuses of feeling
bored and just wasting your time away
now that you're spending a lot of time
at home with your family and probably
cooking a lot more often
this can also lead to overeating i mean
come on mom's home-cooked meals
are the best everyone is enjoying it and
we have to finish it
just to keep her happy let's face it
sometimes
our own family members can be an
unintentional saboteur
by encouraging us to keep eating and
eating come on eat more darling i made
these cookies and these buns
you got to try them they're delicious
eat
keep finishing it yes if you have such
friends or family members you need to
learn when to say
no and that you have had enough of food
it will be challenging especially to
your family
but if you can have an open conversation
with them and share with them
your fitness goals then perhaps they can
be more understanding
and supportive towards you
ladies you know very well what i'm
talking about you've been eating
so well and a few days right before your
period
bam your hormone changes and you
suddenly crave for
all the bad stuff this is so me in fact
it just happened to me a couple of days
ago
i lost control and just wanted sweet
desserts
savory snacks and nothing seemed to
satisfy me
and i ended up with a bloated tummy you
don't have to deprive yourself but what
is important is that you're aware of
the hormonal changes that are happening
in your body
so when you indulge eat in a mindful way
and enjoy your food with all your senses
you will feel satisfied with less
and you will be in control of the
situation soon
the cravings will start to fade away and
you'll find balance again
for the next three days i want you to
record every single thing you eat
and then determine what kind of hunger
it was ask yourself
why did you eat were you physically
hungry or were you just stressed or
bored
was it a habit-based decision or because
everyone else was eating
write it down and share your thoughts
with me in the comments below
by recognizing which hunger you're
experiencing you'll be able to take the
right approach
to satisfy it and stop overeating
eventually
you'll be in control of your eating
habits rather than allowing your
emotions or surroundings
to control you so let me know your
experience and thoughts
in the comments below if you find these
tips to be useful then
do give this video a thumbs up share it
on with your family members and friends
and do also hit the subscribe button if
you haven't yet subscribed
check out my youtube channel for a lot
more home workout videos
healthy recipes and also meal plans to
help you get started in
your fitness journey and i will see you
in my next video
all the best